just before his army invaded ukraine
vladimir putin outlined his motivations
in a speech
his first and main argument
expansion
he blamed the extensions of the military
alliance ever closer to russia's borders
and accused western leaders of breaking
alleged promises to never do so
but experts disagree on whether that's
true the us broke these assurances and
these commitments that had been made i
think that's false it's really sort of a
pretext
so was anything really promised
and why is that such a crucial point for
russia
after world war ii two spheres of
influence emerged in europe each one
with their military alliance
nato in the west
countries that would soon be part of the
warsaw pact in the east
[Music]
this created a clear red line between
the two superpowers their spheres of
influence were clearly defined and for
many years nato grew slowly
[Music]
until 1990 when that divide started to
crumble here in germany
in germany was the key focal point of
the cold war in europe
joshua schifrisson has done extensive
archival research on the us and soviet
foreign policy including this great
question of what or was not promised in
1990. at the time germany was speeding
towards reunification
and for many in europe this was a bit
scary
the u.s did not want to see
a reunified germany either in the soviet
camp
or neutral right and the concern with
neutrality was that a neutral germany
might one day run amok washington
decided the best option was to bring
germany into nato but first they had to
convince the soviets and here we get to
those famous assurances about nato's
expansion
[Music]
in february of 1990 in a series of
meetings us and west german leaders very
openly said
that if the soviet leadership consented
to german reunification in germany in
reunified germany remaining in nato
then nato would not expand one inch to
the east
[Music]
logs of those conversations have since
been declassified and they show what
soviet politicians were told by western
leaders like german chancellor hamutko
[Music]
nato secretary general manfred warner
[Music]
and the famous words by u.s secretary of
state james baker not one inch to the
east
what happened to nato after germany
unified
in 1999 the czech republic hungary and
poland joined nato
in 2004 it was the baltic states and
four other countries
and finally four more from 2009 to just
a few years ago george and ukraine were
promised membership in 2008 but are not
yet members
this seems to justify putin's grievances
but one historical event could suggest a
different interpretation
back in 1991 in the collapse of the
soviet union
this is stephen pifer he was the u.s
ambassador to ukraine when nato was
expanding and deputy director on the
soviet desk when those assurances were
made when secretary baker at that time
was talking about nato not extending
forward
i understood that it's not into east
germany
pifer says that those commitments didn't
refer to countries like poland or
lithuania because at that time also i
mean the warsaw pact still existed the
war so i didn't collapse for another
year
so i saw the discussions about not one
inch really in the context of germany
many experts disagree that doesn't quite
hold water uh for two different reasons
one is that the soviet leadership and
the americans both understood that the
question of what comes next in europe
was all about the future of eastern
europe not just east germany there's a
concern the warsaw pact is falling apart
and also if i say to you i'm not going
east
uh it's a pretty generic statement right
it kind of biggers the imagination to
think that they only meant oh east only
there but no further from there
however raises another point when you
look at the actual agreements you know
there were there were no final
commitments by nato not to enlarge in
other words no treaties only
conversations
nothing was written down as we've
established but at the same time
political understandings and commitments
of the sort of diplomatic commitments
carry a lot of water in oral policy this
is how we ended the cuban missile crisis
for example
uh and if it didn't matter why would we
have diplomats talk to each other
regardless of how serious these
assurances were this debate arguably
misses a more important point
states don't uphold
treaties just because they're written
down if those leaders in those states
decide to change course then a treaty is
not going to stand in the way
so all the emphasis on writing things
down
you know it puts the carpet for the
horse
nato's expansion can be better explained
by focusing not on those conversations
but on the countries involved
[Music]
on one side the us whose influence grew
after the fall of the soviet union nato
expansion was fundamentally a byproduct
of the unipolar era right at this moment
in time where the u.s had great power
very few constraints and at least some
policymakers who had an idea that
american power and influence apply to
the world would generate lots of goods
for the united states as well as good
things for the world
on another the countries that joined
nato
it wasn't that nato said let's enlarge
it was you had countries such as poland
emerging from the records of the warsaw
pact saying
we want to be a member of nato we want
to be a member of the european union and
we are prepared to do
all of the things that requires
and finally russia whose motivations are
not limited to nato i think there are
really three reasons behind what russia
is doing one is the geopolitical concern
the russians want a sphere of influence
in the post-soviet space and ukraine is
a very important part of that so they're
trying to bring it back but there are
two other issues at play here one i
think is a domestic political concern
and that is for the kremlin
a western oriented
democratic
economically successful that kind of
ukraine is a nightmare for the kremlin
because it leads to russians asking why
can't we have the same political voice
and the same democratic rights that they
have in ukraine and then there's a third
risk which i just think is it's
is vladimir putin and he's quite
emotional about ukraine he's very
emotional and even angry about it
whether nato should have kept its
assurances is up for debate we
underestimated just how much antipathy
there was in moscow to nato's existence
years of the us downplaying the
assurance that were previously given and
making russia feel like it could not
trust the west have really narrowed the
opportunity to resolve this crisis
but it's really sort of a pretext mr
putin has put together this list of
grievances against the west you know but
he didn't talk about them 20 years ago
but those discussions were important not
only for what they promised
but also for what they showed
a willingness to compromise and to not
cross each other red lines
[Music]
over the years the situation around
russia changed and more countries
decided to join nato
but it changed even more within russia
as putin's grip on power strengthened
and he became more authoritarian
[Music]
and isolated